[Music]
well let's go back to lebanon for
another update
on an aspect of the lebanon story i
guess you could say a judge there has
issued a warrant for the arrest of the
manager of the port in beirut he is
already detained at home
almost 3 000 tons of highly explosive
chemicals stored improperly at the port
blew up on august the 4th more than 200
people were killed
hundreds of thousands were left homeless
stephanie decker joins us live from the
port area
steph what happens to this individual
next
well as you mentioned he's already been
detained around 10 days ago along with
24 others
so we are understanding that his lawyer
can appeal but what basically what this
means is that he is now officially
arrested today he was questioned for
four hours around four hours by the
judge
uh yesterday the head of the customs of
the port
underwent the same kind of questioning
he also had an official arrest
warrant issued so basically what you're
seeing now peter is small steps
in sort of officiating the detention of
the individuals
uh who are in charge of this port as
part of this investigation again this is
an investigation being carried out
by the lebanese you do have the fbi and
the french
involved in it when it comes to the
forensics but certainly interestingly we
were talking to a family a little
earlier today
their husband and father worked at those
silos and actually called them around
half an hour before the explosion
happened
they know exactly where he was and he
says he's still missing
they don't believe the search is
continuing they're getting no
information from anyone
and they say what they want is an
international investigation because they
hold the system here and interesting
your guests were saying that can the
system be reformed well many people here
think
no and they believe that it can only be
an international investigation that gets
real answers
as to what happened here and who is
responsible so even
in its current form the investigation is
multi-agency
multi-country but two points i guess def
point number one
who's pushing it who's driving the
investigation and point number two
how's that going down with the people of
beirut
yes well it's led by the lebanese it
took a while to appoint a judge who
seemed
to be acceptable uh to all sides
which again a lot of people here would
tell you that they were looking for
someone
who was going to be less independent
people here are calling for an
independent investigation peter
because they've lost faith in the elites
in the system in this system that has
been so entrenched here for decades and
that's basically
you know they blame this as a symbol
really of what's endemic here corruption
mismanagement negligence i mean we saw
the protest movement you and i spoke
back in october
when people were protesting against
basic needs saying this is a government
that doesn't even take care of the basic
needs of its people
it doesn't remove sewage it doesn't
provide us with 24-hour electricity
it doesn't provide us with clean water
it doesn't do anything that an elected
government
needs to do it's only more concerned
with lining its pockets and the
catastrophic explosion that you saw
happen here again
allowing that amount of explosive
material to be stored in the middle of a
heavily populated capital i mean you've
seen the pictures
over the last two weeks and just looking
behind the camera it is
a skeleton of a city it is a broken
people the people
i've been speaking to just arriving here
in the last couple of days we'll tell
you
this time it's different we are strong
we've been through civil wars we've seen
assassinations but this time
the explosion came into our homes
unexpected one woman who lost her
husband said
you know it came in it take it took out
our happiness it took out our souls
another man i spoke to a diver a
volunteer who was diving here
in the days after the explosion said
nothing is going to change
it's simply going to continue he said
but again this is different we've all
been traumatized and he says i think
you're going to see an exodus of people
you're going to see an excellence of
lebanese
wanting to leave the country because
they've never seen anything like this
before
and certainly a lot of people won't have
hope that anything is going to change
any time soon what's happened to the
city peter has been catastrophic it's
going to take billions of dollars to
rebuild
it's an economy that was already in
tatters people have lost
most of their life savings uh you've had
that you have corona on the rise
it is a it's a very sad situation here
at the moment people not very hopeful
at all stephanie decker thank you steph
decker there are correspondent reporting
live
from beirut